in a world where scammers run amok one
internet detective is ready to call all
of them
out ladies and gentlemen
without further ado i am your sifu
coffeezilla and welcome to fake guru
fridays guys that's right that's
each day has a theme and we're bringing
it back fake guru fridays is one of my
favorite days that i don't know we just
kind of lost it in the mix so we're
bringing it back
and today we're answering an age-old
question which is you know pyramid
schemes are often pitched
to people who don't have much financial
know-how they're usually pitched to
lower income communities
who just don't know better who are
desperate you know you get the idea
nothing on them
it's just this predatory tactic but what
happens
when you try to pitch to real investors
a pyramid scheme
you know an insane idea what do you do
with what a real investors do
when they are pitched insane ideas well
the result
is incredible uh but for this we're
gonna have to go
to the computer so let's go wow
look nice graphics fancy graphics paid a
lot of money for that i hope you guys
appreciate the 10 million dollar studio
guys let's be real
uh very legitimate so see look some
people say it's a green screen can't be
a green screen i'm wearing green right
now so that's impossible
anyways let's get this started shall we
okay oh not the right page
we'll edit that out ladies and gentlemen
this is a man trying to hide behind a
white presentation and he's about to get
destroyed
let me set this up let me set the stage
so this is dragon's den
it's like shark tank if you know it from
the us basically people come
on they pitch their investment ideas to
actual investors who have run
real businesses i'm not saying those
investors are perfect because we've
talked about some of their shady
business dealings but in this case
justice is about to be served it's about
to be served real nice
[Music]
hello dragons my name is andy niakis and
i'm from brampton ontario
i stand humbly before you today to offer
you a historical business
opportunity
already off to a bad start why the big
breath okay
how much money are you looking for andy
i'm looking for 175
000 of your hard-earned dollars which
works out to 35 000
per dragon as i would like all five of
you on board what do we get how much of
the company
uh if you could please let me finish my
pitch i will lead up to it i have
important information it's not a product
that i'm selling
okay go ahead thank you very much man
this guy the balls of this guy already
how do you go
they're investing in you you don't go
hey sir please shut up
i'll take questions at the end of this
presentation
you're so nice arlene i would like all
five of you on board
in exchange you will get a business
package within a rapidly growing company
this business package will be
responsible in the near future
for bringing you huge returns
[Music]
that's the face that i'm giving right
now buzzword buzzword buzzword business
package buzzword buzzword will
get huge returns buzzword in the next
earnings quarter
uh where's the talk about equity what
are your sales
what's the real business this is going
to reward you
with a lot of money in the future
[Music]
instead of all these reward points cards
with clutter and restriction
with one card lioness guarantees you
cash back into your bank account after
your routine purchases
[Music]
how much what percentage uh it can vary
it can go from 20 to 40 percent
wait a second i go buy something i get
20
of yeah that doesn't happen that's not
real that purchase value
in cash yes sir that ain't gonna happen
you got to explain that further because
that's
absolutely absolutely keep going so the
way thank you sir you should be sweating
dude do you guys do you guys see this do
you guys see the sweat on this man's
brow here
this is why the name shark tank is
actually a lot better than dragon's den
because dragons
you know sharks smell blood in the water
they pounce and they're about to rip
this guy to shreds
poor man i feel bad for him because i
don't i don't even think he's at the top
of this thing shush the way it works is
that
the shoppers sign up and register for
free
and
[Music]
excuse me i'm just so nervous i know
this is going to end badly for you i
want you to know that kevin i want you
to
can we make that a meme in our community
as soon as we catch some red flags it's
like
i know this is going to end badly for
you i i want you to know that
i know this is going to end badly for
you i want you to know that kevin i want
you to let this poor man get his picture
very badly
arlene i got to know how i get 20
percent off my retail price we're going
to hear if we let him talk
i you know what i see these things a lot
where like the hosts are not sweating at
all and then the other guy
is the whole time is like sweating
profusely
i think it's a trick of the lights i
think they put the hot lights on the guy
and then they have like cool fans on the
hosts because nobody
normally sweats this much as you'll see
in the next clip too
this isn't just this guy all the people
pitching they're like sweating profusely
and i don't think it's just nerves
which by the way is genius on the
producer's part if that's true
[Music]
the shoppers register for free and uh
lioness partners up with retailers
in to take a sales commission
of the sales they generate that
particular i don't even think this guy
knows what his own company does
i don't think he's the owner of it he
doesn't sound like it like he doesn't he
isn't confident in what his own company
does
this is what all the mlmers do you ask
them what their company does they're
like well we have a distribution chain
of logistics
if you get to the right tier and you get
the the the override
it's going to go ahead and get you rich
they don't understand it
retailer depending on their profit
margin
just like a commission-based salesman in
a company
i get it i don't get it i get it i don't
get it oh
i'm gonna i'm gonna try to explain to
you in a simple term if i can help
you sign us up and then the deal is we
should go sign up other people right
and they sign up other people isn't that
a pyramid scheme
we're eight years old uh in europe
you're dead stop don't hurt yourself bud
and a pyramid scheme falls apart at the
bottom correct
because every time you move to the top
the supporters from this is the shoppers
which register for free right and
they're motivated
to go use their cards at all they're
saying
i don't make any money if someone signs
up underneath me
yes you do i do absolutely oh that's why
it's a pyramid scheme
it's not a pyramid large foot circling
above your head
this whole thing is just a roust i mean
this should honestly this is legal right
here
this is manslaughter right now this poor
man is getting obliterated
does the cost become a business partner
the one
that i bought is ten thousand dollars
and nuts to start in canada
alone andy how much ten thousand dollars
that's ridiculous
well i've i've seen emma lim's for like
500 bucks 10 grand
this poor man he hasn't made his money
back he's this guy's a lowly
peon i guarantee it he acts like it
which every return on your money have
you got now
uh so far i'm on my way zero because
i've been
very busy how many years ago did you
give him the ten thousand
it's like that sweating meme it's just
profusely
i feel bad for this guy at this point
now at this point knowing what i know
he's getting scammed and he's being
humiliated all at the same time
so it is funny because he's trying to
scam other people but
he also is being scammed himself since
you find out in some of these
things it's like you're getting scammed
but you're also scamming other people
it's terrible
uh basically it was in in uh steps the
last payment i made
was about three months ago where i bored
uh money against my house
no no why would you do that don't ever
borrow money against your house this
isn't even a scam thing
this poor man has been hood winked and
bamboozled he went into the most
aggressive entrepreneur show
to try to pitch the very idea that he
got scammed into and try to scam those
people
and this is the face
i gotta perfect that face i gotta get on
these one of these shark tanks sometime
soon because i guarantee actually
no cap as the kids say i'd be a great
shark i'd sniff out all these con
artists liars etc i wouldn't let any of
them through
and this is the face i'd be giving all
of them just like that
because the returns overpower any
percentage when are there returns coming
the returns are uh when you give him 35
000.
wait a second why would an investor give
10 000 to somebody and never get a
return
he's down stop kicking this man while
he's down
you're gonna get a return you're
guaranteed your return as soon as you
find your four directs
ah it's so painful
oh we're starting off faker friday right
boys
hairless sweaty man is not the guru it's
the
structure the multi-level marketing
structure but i'm gonna do it anyway
it's my show so i guess this is fake
guru friday
lioness is the name of the scam by the
way for those who you who are wondering
i don't know if i
told you guys that in the beginning i
thought we were just going to find out
together but yeah
little give back scam who did you buy
this from
my ex-wife in europe honestly
how much has she made it's hard to say
because it's in hungarian florence
this poor man's life is falling apart
and kevin hillary's like
honestly
i think the odds of you getting money
from the dragons is pretty low
gotta be honest why is that it's a it's
a it's a straightforward business i mean
andy we are here's the way it works just
simply
you're losing us line us up here okay
here's me and here's the five dragons
under me
and there's a big foot above you about
to squash
because it's a really stupid idea yeah
just hold on can you finish that analogy
for me so that it's you
yes here's linus here's me yeah and here
comes the five dragons underneath
underneath got it and they start to
build and they each pay me
37 000 for the privilege
of joining a pyramid scheme yeah that's
gonna work their network bigger because
everybody that you bring in they're
gonna bring in so i start here
yes and then it gets bigger and bigger
and bigger and bigger
what did i just make andy
can we get back to this nasty p word the
pyramid scheme
ah so we start here oops
uh-huh and he's like yeah yeah
what did i make andy oh this poor man
you gotta feel bad for him you do is
illegal my friend
this is not something that i would ever
invest in and neither should you have
you have i'm out yup i don't know if
it's a pyramid or not
it is but my reaction is i'm
in my opinion i'm looking at you lioness
lawyers in my opinion
okay maybe it is maybe it isn't that's
why he said that actually is literally
so he doesn't get sued
not comfortable selling this to any of
my friends
for business associates so i'm out
andy i don't think you should take any
more money and invested in this
it might not be a good idea i'm out
absolutely no way would i put money into
this
this stuff is distasteful i'm out
oh that's a good one distasteful so all
right
finish this up it doesn't impress me
i am not impressed by the got this guy
it's operating as well
so for that reason i'm out
okay thank you they'll take that with
you
thanks you guys will see you'll all see
when i'm worth a hundred million dollars
and i've sold
gift cards and credit card give backs to
everybody in the entire world you'll see
what fools you were
now if you're like me and you just saw
that guy get eviscerated on national
television
i'd stay away if you're one of these
pyramid scheme guys
but no no no the thing with pyramid
scheme people and this is the truth this
is honest
they believe in themselves like deep
down to the core
they've been indoctrinated that this
pyramid scheme is going to change the
world
so they often they don't see like what
everyone else sees and you're about to
see that
oh
this is already off to a bad start when
you look like you're about to try to
revive frankenstein with your little
science experiment from the third grade
this is not gonna go well there's
nothing sexy about what i'm seeing right
now
hello dragons my name is uh paul lobo
this is barry ritchie okay our company
is air
oasis limited the purpose of us being
here
is we want 125 000 pounds of your money
and in return we will give you 10 equity
in our company our product produces
water out of air and barry is now going
to give you a brief
so it's a dehumidifier like a
thing that exists already presentation
ambitious plans for market penetration
barry richie and paul lobos pitch for
125
000 pounds of investment in their
company air oasis
certainly hasn't lacked confidence but
what's behind their confident claims
theo perfetus wants to know
barry paul i'm theo hi nice to meet you
7p
elite yes sounds cheap when you compare
it with bottled water
yes but it's not cheap when you compare
it
to just filter because there's units
like that there's filter existing that's
right
without question without question the
difference is these don't need
a water supply so they will be very good
in humid countries
without question where you can't get
water
to a unit most definitely so the uk
market is not actually going to be a
very good market for this is it
well i think it is actually there's a
lot of people that are interested in
reducing their car
oh no no no no no no no no
i can already tell who this salesman is
the guy talking right now not this guy
the guy talking
he's the salesman who everything always
fits his product
like you come out of the store and he's
like oh do you need a mattress and
you're like oh no i already have a bed
and he goes no no mattresses are great
for people who already have beds and
you're like no no i just bought a
mattress yesterday he's like
actually this mattress is great for
people who just bought a mattress
yesterday you're like no
this doesn't fit what i need right now
and what is it costing you to buy these
they're coming into me oh oh
the sweat begins again i'm telling you
they have
heaters on these people so that they
sweat during the presentation i know it
because this is not a normal amount of
human sweat
barry and paul are confident of healthy
margins
but duncan banertine thinks he's spotted
a flaw in their plans
now term i don't like about his product
is something you said in your pitch
what you're going to do is educate the
public you haven't explained how you're
going to educate the public
and you're not going to educate the
public they're probably going to
continue using tap water
or drinking bottled water yep duncan as
soon as you do this
test which is very visual it's really
that's the educational you can't travel
around the country knocking in people's
doors
look at how arrogant this hand raises
i've never seen something worse than
this
i would never invest in somebody who has
this face on
this is the smuggest face i've ever seen
and i know it's london or the uk
but this is pretty bad even for you guys
cutting people's doors
going in with two glasses of water and
sending people look at the difference
buy one of these machines you can't do
that yes we can you can't
educate the public we've just got 100
kits
in little cases this is like the kirby
vacuum cleaner this is the bugs under
the on the bed under the microscope
we've got 300 people signed up
to go out door-to-door and commission
his mother buddy the point i'm making
isn't that you can't go around knocking
on doors
the point i'm making is you can't afford
to go around knocking on doors
oh really caught on no actually let me
make this more accurate
gotta get a little a little water here
hold on ah it's gonna be too much
alright no it's good
oh really really i can't do it really
huh there's not enough money to go
knocking on doors and saying to people
look
will you let me come in and show you
these two glasses of water and show you
the difference you know you can buy my
machine for 500 quid
okay but there is because there doesn't
cost any we've bought all the kits
the people are taking on a part-time
commission only basis they get a hundred
pounds of sale they do three in a week
they get 150 percent
it's good old-fashioned pyramid
multi-level direct marketing
you know you see he got himself it's
good old-fashioned pyramid scenes
uh multi-level uh markets
it's good old-fashioned pyramid
multi-level direct market
did you see he went through oh gosh i
have to explain something for you guys
to fully get the context of this
pyramid it used to be called pyramid
selling then they rebranded it after
everyone realized that was a scam to
multi-level marketing
everyone realized that was a scam so
they renamed it to direct selling this
guy
has been in the game so long that he
goes through fluidly
all three words for it seamlessly oh
this is incredible
surprise i've done the lots i had
you run the risk of talking yourself
back down those stairs without an
investment
okay the reason i asked if you've been a
kirby selling person
is that i could have told you were
because actually what you used to do is
stand in people's room bombard them and
barrage them exactly the way you're
trying to do with us now
until they capitulate and buy that
carpet cleaner
i've seen the selling techniques which i
have to say really
really annoys me you are talking about
this guy's confidence is slowly
diminishing if you see
the face is getting sweatier
both of ours are and uh the confidence
is going away the smugness going away
didn't have all the answers he thought
he did but a pyramid
selling scheme i've got to tell you for
me that is a combination that i would
run a mile from okay that's fine so
i have no reason to invest i'm out
the atmosphere in the den is darkening a
furious debra meden wants nothing to do
with the duo
and she's not the only dragon to be
alienated by the pitch
as a business proposition does this
excite me for 150 000 pounds
no working with barry would just drive
me
crazy i don't think i could handle it
and for those reasons guys
i'm out
this guy's getting eviscerated and
nobody's coming to save him that's my
favorite part
two dragons are out paul how do you work
with this guy
um very well um i i love his enthusiasm
no i don't know i i get barry i don't
get you leaving
you do everything barry says no not at
all
two men and a business always agree one
of them is unnecessary what
i only see one unnecessary man here how
much money have you made
have you got money to put into it yes i
have i put i put in
150 000 pounds so you put in 150 000 of
your own cash
yes and barry i'm about 50 and about
a million in hard work this man is so
sassy
can i just say i had about a million of
hard work
relax dude yes you gotta have the right
partner in a partnership and barry's not
cutting it
i gotta say have you got any more money
paul
of course i've got more money how much
more money have you got well
i don't think that concerns you it does
concern me how much money have you got
you're asking for an investment of
course it concerns him how much his
investors have to put in the business
that
may be failing very soon this is rough
probably about 10 million in the in the
bank that say i don't think that's a
valid question
well i'll tell you why it's a valid
question if you've got the money why
aren't you putting the
let me let us explain why we want your
your expertise your your knowledge so
that we can
really go but why should i give you
money for you to get money from me
well we're not a charity we're not going
to let you have uh they're not a charity
they could just look at this guy
my face when gurus try to pitch me a
pyramid scheme on dragon's den
do you want my knowledge from me and my
money absolutely exactly absolutely
that's why we're here i haven't got mug
written over my forehead you know
i'm i don't know british but i'm
assuming that that's a big insult
mug i don't know my uk editor is gonna
have to explain that one to me
an enraged peter jones has blasted the
duo
the dragons are clearly infuriated by
the entrepreneurs themselves
buddy can you give him a glass of water
barry and paul's only hope now is to
salvage their pitch
by proving their water tastes as good as
they say this is good this is good
reset the pitch yes your pyramid scheme
but maybe your pyramid scheme tastes
great
buddy it tastes terrible it tastes
terrible
well i've had all these conversations
but nobody's sort of tasting the water
taste that water that's because it's
warm that's why unusual taste
oh no unusual taste that's a bad
adjective for water unusual
there don't be really good clean glass
there's something in it
there's nothing in it use your glass and
go and get a drink
watch it mayhem erupts in the den you
thought they were sweating before
it's just getting started
the dragons declare barry and paul's
water to be totally unpalatable it's
revolting
my kids will throw that back at you theo
perfetus
demands an explanation guys i swear i
can explain
nation taste it does it taste terrible
or not
it's it doesn't say it's terrible but it
certainly doesn't taste as good as it
should do
it doesn't the machine but it's a brand
spanking new machine that needed to be
flushed and everything else properly
this is
it's a brand's making new machine that
doesn't work
i don't know what's going on here guys
it needs to be set
up for a longer period of time in order
for five hours to get it working
properly so what is the temperature
what hey i'll tell you how long it takes
to get your tap water
just four to five hours
uh 21 degrees just listen to me i'm
getting really annoyed now
i'm complaining not about the
temperature but the fact
it's got a terrible appalling aftertaste
so don't make excuses about the
temperature i'm out
it's all but over for barry and paul
they've been
blasted by theopa pathetis now duncan
bannertine and peter jones stepped
forward
to have their say you know the thing
what gets me is this you did all these
tests in this water to show your water
is the best yes yes then i tested your
water
yes yes and it's rubbish yes we all
tested it we all said the same thing
yes and then you said that's because
that machine hasn't been flushed
yes in order for it for you to
see our machine in his full operation it
would have been fair for this machine to
be here overnight
then it would have been where you've
gone from they would have you've gone
from justice you've gone from an hour
and a half
to all night now you know but it doesn't
really answer my question
um and you know i'm not gonna invest in
it so i'm out
paul barry you've basically bought a
product here that lives or dies
on the back of the quality that it
produces can i say in all the times
that he doesn't even make a point he
just goes of the quality that it
produces
i'm gonna say in all the times that
we've tasted that water
amongst you dragons that's the first
time it's unfortunate being like this
that's all i can say to you i think
enough has been said by everybody else
and
i don't think you're here necessarily to
be insulted
so good luck in your endeavors but i'm
not going to invest in the business and
i'm out
okay okay fair enough barry and paul
have felt the full
force of the all right and that's it
guys that's how you
invest in a or that's how you pitch a
pyramid scheme on
dragon's den rough
even for me get a little get a fan in
here
uh actually hold on i think we can
10 million studio guys we got fan
technology
uh anyways i hope you enjoyed this
lighthearted episode of
fake guru friday in this case the fake
guru
is pyramid schemes and i guess the
people getting scammed are the people
investing in those pyramid schemes and
taking them on these reality shows
to be trashed in front of the entire
world i hope you learned your lesson
guys
don't do it again thank you for watching
gosh it feels good to be daily huh it
used to be i took the weekend off but
now
hey see you tomorrow